grazie ecco io sono testimone perché
rappresento effettivamente un docente
tipo della scuola italiana
nel senso che ho 61 anni quindi sono
molto vecchia e il mio 42 esimo anno di
insegnamento
quindi ho vissuto tutti gli aspetti
della scuola e soprattutto insegna
latino
però devo dire che ho avuto una
esperienza un'avventura che io mi vorrei
raccontare l'avventura dell'incontro con
il digitale con le tecnologie con un
nuovo modo di fare didattica con
l'esigenza di cambiare la scuola e di
cambiare il modo di approcciarmi con gli
studenti
prima di tutto ci sono stati due momenti
importantissimi nella mia vita uno e
questo steve jobs quando ha presentato
l'ipad nel 2010 ha in america io ho
pensato ma perché non prendiamo l'ipad e
lo mettiamo in classe eva settembre 2010
prima in italia non si sapeva
assolutamente cosa futuri tablet nella
maniera più assoluta
quando sono arrivati mi sono arrivati in
mano questi tablet cominciato a pensare
ma dov'è il mouse come si scaricano che
cos'è un app non sapevo assolutamente
cosa potesse essere non messa in mano a
dei ragazzi e questa è la mia classe che
sta andando alla maturità una foto di un
red che è venuta a seguirci e con loro
ha incominciato a sperimentare che cosa
voleva dire inserire dei dispositivi
mobili
nella classe la prima cosa che passa
estremamente chiara era che non potevamo
più avere dei una didattica tradizionale
frontale dovevamo lavorare insieme e
dovevamo strutturare un nuovo modo di
fare scuola di interagire fra di noi di
collaborare di condividere i organizzano
i gruppi organizzavo i ruoli applicavano
il cooperative learning
abbiamo studiato tantissimo abbiamo
documentato abbiamo fatto vedere questi
nuovi modi di fare scuola per un anno
siamo stati solo noi e poi ci siamo
diffusi in tutta italia
ci siamo diffusi in tutta italia
documentando
solo lavoro scrivendo dei libri
pubblicizzandole pubblicandoli e
facendoli conoscere su questa è andato
anche un centro studi che si chiama
impara digitale e abbiamo incominciato a
pensare come questo cambiamento della
didattica possa influenzare fortemente
la nostra società perché l'azienda più
grande d'italia la scuola ma intorno
alla scuola cioè non ci sono soltanto i
docenti il personale che vive nella
scuola ma soprattutto le famiglie che
noi dobbiamo sempre accompagnare nel
nostro percorso di cambiamento della
scuola ed ero convinta che funzionasse
ero convintissima che funzionasse
ero convinta che i nostri ragazzi
lavorando così intorno a un tavolo
potessero essere veramente protagonisti
del loro sapere bene abbiamo fatto un
evento che si chiamava il processo della
scuola digitale dove io avevo davanti
1.200 ragazzi 600 pro il seicento contro
ho girato tutta italia e mi sono accorta
che i ragazzi non erano contenti i
ragazzi non erano felici di usare le
tecnologie in questo modo non erano
soddisfatti vivevano il nostro modo di
proporre la scuola come un ulteriore
trasmissione del sapere da parte del
docente nei loro confronti
loro non erano liberi allora un ragazzo
mi ha fatto cambiare completamente idea
e da lì è veramente cambiato la mia
avventura nel digitale un ragazzo che
aveva dell'enorme difficoltà dislessico
disgrafico ma con cui non riuscivo in
alcun modo ad avere un colloquio che non
si inseriva mai con gli altri ragazzi
con cui ho io dice voti personali sul
suo apprendimento
gli faccio raggiungere competenze ma non
ci riuscivo in alcuna maniera un giorno
è venuto da me e mi ha detto
professoressa lei mi sta parlando tanto
di conflitti perché era un tema che
stavamo trattando posso trasmettere una
cosa per conto mio per trasmetterle
quello che io penso e mi ha fatto un
video il gelato quattro ore di tempo si
aggregato con gli altri ragazzi in
maniera assolutamente volontaria e mi ha
fatto questo video che chiedo di
trasmettere
ecco questo video mi ha fatto veramente
pensare ho capito una cosa fondamentale
oltre il messaggio che questo ragazzo mi
voleva dare è che lui voleva creare e mi
stava comunicando il suo pensiero
attraverso questo video ha scelto lui le
persone con cui lavorare
bravo lui mi ha chiesto di essere libero
nel produrre e nel trasferire nel
trasformare il suo pensiero
io ho capito questo e ho capito che
dovevo trasformare la mia scuola
dovevo trasformare la mia classe dovevo
liberare spazi dovevo lasciare liberi i
ragazzi di muoversi che non significa
non dare regole dare un ambiente
liberante non vuol dire lasciarli liberi
ma ho tolti i banchi questa è la classe
come appare oggi ma i ragazzi devono
essere liberi di potessi scegliere il
loro percorso di apprendimento con chi
andare a lavorare come fare ricerca e io
non devo dare loro trasmettere loro
soltanto regole e informazioni ma mi
devo mettere con loro io sono sempre
seduta insieme a loro talvolta seduta
sui banchi
insieme a loro gli do moltissimi libri
da leggere perché il digitale non deve
mai sostituire il libro di carta questo
non sognavo cieli digitale non
sostituisce tradizionale gli ho chiesto
ai miei ragazzi ma voi per essere per
venire a scuola volentieri cosa vorreste
e mi hanno risposto per fare a scuola
come a casa
allora io non ho soldi non ho niente una
vecchia scuola non ho non ho queste
strutture è una scuola liceo scientifico
lussana di bergamo e quindi abbiamo
semplicemente spostato manchi messo una
biblioteca di carta messo un
videoproiettore che trasmette in sede
video fintanto quando la regione
lombardia ha deciso di darmi un premio
su questo progetto che abbiamo
trasportato in tutta italia che
moltissime scuole adesso stanno
applicando il metodo proprio di impara
digitale e anche perché questo comporta
un modo diverso di guardare i nostri
ragazzi
questo modo loro possono creare possa
essere autonomi possono veramente
lavorare in team collaborare e
condividere cioè quelle competenze
trasversali
raggiungere quelle competenze
trasversali di cui parlavamo fin quando
non ha incontrato daniele lago che è
venuto ha parlato con me e ho fatto
vedere questa mia idea di scuola e lui
me l'ha trasformata così ecco questa
sarà la scuola che noi andremo ad esso a
ricostruire con parquet e questa è con
lampade con tendaggi in un ambiente dove
vedete non ci sono banchi colorati non
ci sono sedie con le rotelle ma
rappresenta un ambiente dove caldo che
sembra una scusa un aula un salotto di
casa
l'ho fatto vedere a 14 classi e tutti
mettendolo in paragone ad altre modalità
di arredi scolastici e di grandi
tecnologie qui ce ne saranno ma ce ne
saranno quelle quanto basta per essere
abilitanti ad imparare ad aggiungere
competenze la tecnologia non deve essere
un fine ma lo strumento abilitante e la
didattica che deve cambiare lo star bene
dei ragazzi il creare insieme agli altri
a condividere e ad essere non stressati
dalla presenza di un docente che deve
diventare il ricercatore mentore che
deve accompagnarli nel loro percorso nel
loro processo e quindi questo ambiente è
stato votato all'unanimità e adesso
riusciremo a costruirlo almeno per
alcune classi lo prenderemo come modello
di nuova scuola una scuola a casa
naturalmente non ci siamo fermati a
questo abbiamo costruito anche dei
modelli di scuola scomponendo le classi
dalla prima alla quarta ma mettendoli
aggregando gruppi non per gruppi classe
ma gruppi di competenze noi facciamo
laboratori per far raggiungere le
competenze digitali hanno già fatto cod
in robotica domotica stampante 3d
tutti i corsi che loro i laboratori che
gli stessi ragazzi svolgono lo son i
docenti anzi docenti con la scusa di
andare a controllare se i ragazzi sono
buoni o lo sono buoni sono gli appare
gli studenti a prendere appunti ad
imparare perché noi impariamo tantissimo
dei nostri ragazzi e quindi abbiamo
scomposto la scuola facciamo anche
laboratori ad esempio su come si
argomenta laboratori su come il mondo
si sa può recuperare il mondo classico e
facciamo tutti i de crew p in cui
ragazzi vanno a seconda del loro livello
di competenza raggiunta non se sanno non
sanno bene un argomento questo
chiaramente lo dovranno sapere le
conoscenze sono fondamentali ma e
fondamentali che le conoscenze vengono
acquisite attraverso dei percorsi che
possano far raggiungere competenze ai
nostri studenti è un modo nuovo di
intendere la scuola a cui ci dobbiamo
preparare a cui tutti i nostri docenti
dovranno con cui dovranno fare i conti i
nostri docenti ci riusciranno io credo
molto di sé il piano razionale scuola
digitale ci dà la possibilità e gli
strumenti per poterlo fare i
finanziamenti per poterlo fare
adesso i docenti non hanno più alibi i
docenti e la scuola deve rinnovarsi se
vogliamo pensare ad un futuro migliore
per i nostri ragazzi perché le aziende
questo vogliono perché il mondo del
lavoro questo vuole e noi dobbiamo far
conto del mondo del lavoro perché
eticamente corretto dare un futuro ai
nostri studenti
noi siamo ormai impara digitale si è
sviluppata in tutta italia
andiamo ovunque abbiamo raggiungiamo
fino a 950 mila contatti grazie ai
nostri partner facciamo formazione e
facciamo detour che ci portano ad esso
in tutta italia dove i protagonisti sono
gli studenti e docenti
questo è ciò che noi intendiamo come
scuola una scuola vista dagli o con gli
occhi dei ragazzi
noi pensiamo sempre di dover essere noi
di perché perdiamo carisma se ci
rivolgiamo ai nostri studenti non è vero
guardate non è proprio vero
sapete che cosa hanno detto questo
ragazzo con tutte queste problematiche
ad esso in quarta questo ragazzo non è
più mio alunno è venuto da me l'altro
giorno e mi ha detto professoressa io la
ringrazio tantissimo perché lei mi ha
ascoltato e soprattutto mi ha preso sul
serio ecco questa è la frase su cui
vorrei veramente lasciare il mondo della
scuola
prendiamo sul serio i nostri ragazzi
ascoltiamoli veramente guardiamo gli
occhi guardiamo con i loro occhi la
scuola quando noi progettiamo facciamo
le programmazioni di solito siamo sempre
chiusi nelle stanze dei docenti
programmiamo poi andiamo diamo il
materiale nostri docenti studenti questa
è la programmazione dell'anno scolastico
bene io ho deciso di aprire anche quelle
porte la programmazione si fa con i
ragazzi
ascoltiamoli perché ci daranno sempre
dei suggerimenti terribili ciò non
toglie e meravigliosi terribili
significa meravigliosi
ciò non toglie che noi siamo i
veicolatori del sapere e aiutarli nella
conoscenza ma io sono sicura che loro
futuro passerà per una didattica e una
scuola completamente nuova e questa è
una delle proposte
grazie